[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Hello
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
TORU YOSHIKAWA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
EIJI KITAMURA:
MALE SPEAKER 4: Ahoy,
me hearties!
MALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
RETO MEIER: This week, neither
one of us are wearing pants.
MARY GROVE: We have an
audience question.
How does that affect the way
we evaluate potential
investments, especially
at the seed level?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to Google
Developers Live at I/O 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, head of GDL.
And joining me today is my
co-host Daniel Sieberg.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Louis, thanks so
much for having me here at
GDL Live at I/O 2013.
This is actually my second I/O.
And I believe it's your
forth, right?
LOUIS GRAY: It's my fourth I/O.
I went twice as press.
And it's my second year
here as Googler.
I'm really excited about what
we've got in stage for GDL at
I/O. We have exclusive
interviews kicking off from
the stage in Moscone really
back-to-back.
Right between every single
session, so not a single
minute is wasted for those of
you on the live-stream.
Really excited about that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
absolutely.
We've got 5500 folks here,
but lots more watching,
wherever you are.
And part of my job will be to,
not only be here with you
chatting on occasion, but to
actually go out and talk to
the developers in the sandboxes,
our partners.
Learn from them about what
they're working on
and bring that here.
We'll see some of that content
today and then some of it
tomorrow as well.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely,
I'm looking forward
that a great deal.
You're going to talk with
partners from Google+, Drive,
Maps, and YouTube.
And while you're away doing the
hard work, I'm going to be
back here, holding
down the fort.
We're going to be talking with
Megan Smith of Google X to
talk about moonshots.
We'll be talking to people on
Blink, Performance Alley,
Ingress, and some really hot
topics that everybody wants to
know about.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
Fantastic keynote, of course,
to a kick all of this off.
We've got a lot of work to do.
We've got an amazing lineup.
I feel like I should go roll
up my sleeves and get at it
here, right?
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
So I definitely appreciate
you joining me.
For those of you on the live
stream, we definitely want you
follow Google Developers
on YouTube.
Subscribe, so you don't
miss a single moment.
I'll be right back here in a
couple of minutes with Megan
Smith of Google X to
talk moonshots.